good news for Jay Leno released from the  hospital today  his Burns included the lower half of his  face his cheeks and his chin and his  ears and his neck this was Jay this  morning smiling with Hospital staff  after a 10-day stay at the Grossman Burn  Center in addition to Burns to his face  and chest you can see Jay's hand was  also injured during a fire at his home  garage is there a chance that Jay could  have permanent disfigurement with  aggressive care and a little bit of good  luck or we'll be able to get him through  this with the minimal long-term effects  we're told Jay is looking forward to  spending Thanksgiving living with his  family and friends his doctor said today  he's quote optimistic that he will make  a full recovery I've had to tell him  that for the time being he needs to sit  back and take care of Jay  [Music]